you
[Music]
everyone to today's webinar we're going
to talk about reproducible examples from
a conceptual point of view and why
they're surprisingly important and then
also a great deal from a mechanical
point of view how to make your
reproducible examples in a way that
they're easy to share with other people
this short link the R stood that IO
repre Comus it will always point to
something very relevant to this package
that will link to absolutely everything
else so the first thing I want to do is
show basic usage and we're just going to
get right into it and then we'll unpack
what you just saw so I'm sitting here in
an art studio session it's fresh and I
have a little bit of code up here and my
source editor I'm gonna make a factor X
a factor Y I'm gonna combine them and
and get what to most of us is kind of a
puzzling result so this is just going to
be an example of a small piece of code
that maybe you want to talk about on the
community site or share with your local
our expert and ask like what's going on
so this is how you would use reference
to turn this little snippet of code into
a reproducible example this is the path
of least resistance we'll talk about
other methods later so I would select a
little piece of code and copy it to my
clipboard then over in the our console
I'm going to type rep ryx and you will
see that that little piece of code is
run and then basically a beautiful
attractive version of that is stored on
my clipboard and I can preview it here
so if I were to paste the contents of my
clipboard right now you actually see
what's called markdown and this is
what's necessary to create the
attractive version of this code and why
is this helpful because you can go
to places like github the art studio
community site or Stack Overflow and
paste this markdown in so I'm going to
show you what this would look like in a
github issue so that's that same
markdown that you just saw github lets
you preview things and you'll see that
it looks just the way it did locally for
me it's been rendered it's syntax
highlighted we have a tiny little ad
down here that tells people how you did
this and I could submit that as a github
issue so that is the basic process and
the reason I can just type repres is
that I always have this package attached
and so you might need to call this and
we're gonna talk a great deal about that
next so that is what basic repres
usage looks like it creates a small
little piece of code renders it nicely
and it's ready to paste into other
formats so this is just a static version
of what we just did and this is the gift
that I use on the recs website I
rewatched this clip that's from a movie
called Jerry Maguire it's still highly
recommended and basically the reason for
bothering to do all of this is if you're
going somewhere to have a conversation
about are to have questions answered or
to describe a bug in software
being careful about how you make your
reproducible example makes it much much
much easier for other people to help you
and I want to explain where this word
came from repres
so Roman first tweeted this and I
thought it was just a great made-up word
so it is short for reproducible example
so it is a completely made-up word but
it's just very handy and I'm going to
use the word repres
over and over and over again in this
webinar so I want to be very clear that
I'm
using it and I'd say three like distinct
but related ways so I think people at
least in the small art community are
starting is to say repre kissed as a
noun like it is a reproducible example
and that has nothing to do with whether
you use this package or not but then
today's webinar is going to show you use
of a package with that same name repres
that you can install from cran I'll show
you how to do that in just a moment and
then this is a pretty small package it
has a couple functions but really the
main function it has is also called rep
ryx so this webinar is going to talk
about how to use the rep recs function
inside the reference package to produce
a good-looking reproducible example and
when is this come up in your life it's
very handy for conversations that you
have on community our studio comm it's
very handy for preparing questions or
answers for Stack Overflow it's very
handy for reporting bugs or making
feature requests for an hour package
that is developed on github and also
very useful for having detailed
conversations about our and slack or an
email so a reproducible example
conceptually is useful in all of those
places and then this package rep ryx
smooths over some of the mechanics so
here I wanted to talk to you about what
you're going to need to do on your
computer to make this package available
to yourself
so reference does not come with our it
does not come with our studio you have
to make an explicit effort to install it
so you should pick one of these methods
and it's the type of thing that you do
once per computer so you could use
install that packages open quote wrapper
X close quote to install just the rep
Rex package it
is also part of the meta package that we
call tidy verse so if you did install
that package as tidy verse repres would
be one of the many packages that get
installed on your machine in general
there is very little harm that you can
do to yourself by reinstalling packages
so you also should not stress out too
much about you know you could stop you
could install just repres and then
install the tiny burrs and nothing bad
will happen so do it once per machine
just because that's the minimum you need
to do but it's no tragedy if you
reinstall things once you've installed
you still need to use our sort of
library call to make the recs functions
available in your our session so you
would need to do this in every our
session that you plan to use refworks in
so that might be something that you do
multiple times per day certainly way way
way way more than once per computer so
every time you want to use the package
you'll need to execute the library
repres command now I use repres several
times a day in the most part and so that
would be very annoying so an alternative
if you also have a comment semi-heavy
user of this package is to make it
available to yourself all the time so
you can control the start up behavior of
our through a file called our profile
and conventionally its found in your
home directory and so this snippet of
code suppress messages require reference
looks a little different from what you
just saw but it's sort of a better way
to attach this package in your in your
startup file so you would put this
snippet of code there and your our
profile and then forevermore when you
start our the wrapper X package would be
available and if you have never thought
about your our profile file before there
is a function and they use this package
which you would also have to install
that will create it for you if you don't
have it or if you do have it it would
open it for you
for editing in case you wanted to put
something like this snippet in there so
once you've done those two things you've
installed it and you've attached it
through either the library command or by
putting something in your dar profile
you are ready to use the Rex function
and what you saw me do in that first
demo was I actually called the Rex
function explicitly in our console and
something you'll see me do before we're
done is we also have put some what are
called our studio add-ins into this
package that give you even more ways to
launch this function I this is a bit of
a sidebar but but since I have shown you
how to put things in your our profile
file I also want to tell you how to do
that responsibly so rep ryx is a
workflow package it's something you
would use in your daily work to make
your life a little bit easier you use it
interactively I would be pretty shocked
to see it show up in a typical person's
our scripts are markdown files packages
or shiny apps and so the fact that it
doesn't show up in those things it's an
interactive package makes it safe to
attach and your our profile but I don't
want you to get the wrong idea and think
oh my god I should do this with all my
packages so I would not want to see this
kind of code using like deployer ggplot2
or things that do show up in your
scripts and it's because your scripts
would then become highly not
self-contained and they they would work
for you because of stuff in your art
profile but they won't work for other
people so this is an interesting
technique to know about but you need to
be really really careful about what you
do here so I think it's safe to put rep
Rex in there it is not safe to put deep
IR in there okay so we're going to get
back to the package and to reproducible
examples now so I wanted to give a brief
intro like what on earth in my life
drove me to make this one of my missions
before I joined our
studio I was a professor at the
University of British Columbia and I had
a course called stat 545 that has a lot
of content online to this day the course
continues you could go there and I ran
this course entirely on github and so it
meant that all of my dialogue with
students both sort of me to the whole
class and and me talking to individual
students took place and github issues
and I actually analyzed my github usage
and the course and I found that every
fall I was participating in at least 300
any 500 github issue threads and that's
just in my teaching life so I spend a
great deal of time talking about are in
those places and solving people's our
problems and to do that well I actually
wanted to use executable our code and
the friction involved in making that
look good started to drive me crazy and
now that I'm no longer a full-time
faculty member and I'm working full-time
on our packages this just gives you a
sense of the intensity of my github
activity over the last year so now I can
still work with tons and tons of github
issues you know in a different capacity
and then I also talked about our a lot
in slack so I still have this sort of
hourly need to run little pieces of our
code and share what I'm seeing with
other people so try to remove friction
for myself and other people led me to
create a few principles that I knew had
to be true of a tool to make this easier
so this is the replica la sofy I think
that conversations about code are much
more productive if they contain three
things well it's one thing but three
properties code that actually runs okay
code that I do not have to run as the
reader but code
that I can easily run and so there is a
little bit of self-contradiction here
but the point is you want to make it
easy for people to interact with your
reproducible example in a whole bunch of
different ways they can just be a
consumer they can just read it or they
can easily grab it and run it themselves
modify it and share that back with you
so I want to be really detailed about
what I mean when I say code that
actually runs so you're gonna isolate a
little piece of our code and you hand it
off to repres you've seen one demo we're
about to do a whole bunch more that code
is taken and it is run in a completely
new our session and that means it has to
be completely self-contained so it must
include the command to load all
necessary packages and it must create
all necessary objects and this can be
very frustrating for people but it's
extremely important so I'm going to go
do this live if to show exactly what I
mean
okay so I'm looking at an R script that
contains the code you just saw on that
side and I'm going to restart R so let's
imagine like a typical interactive our
session so I'm gonna be down in the
console here and I'm gonna say oh I'd
like to play a little bit with this
crazy package I've heard about so there
I go I say library praise done on the
console now up in my source editor I
make a new object called template and
it's a template string exclamation your
rep Rex is adjective and so if I then
call the praise function from the praise
package I don't expect you to know this
I'm just using it as an example it's
gonna create like random little
sentences for us praising someone for
their awesome reference so let's say I
want to share my joy about this with
people using the Rex package I would
select this little snippet of code again
this is the long way I'll show you a
short way later copy it go down to the
console type repres and hit return and
now let's look at the preview here it
shows defining template and then my
praise call fails error and praise could
not find function praise and that's
because you don't have the library
praise command here so over in that
fresh our session the priest package is
not available to use so here's something
else you might do you're like okay I'm
gonna add that command then I'm gonna
make my call to the package let's see if
that works copy call rep Rex again I
have a new error error and grep whatever
whatever objects template not found so
this snippet is incomplete in a
different way
it actually doesn't contain the code
that defines the template object so
here's the full snippet it loads the
Krays package it defines the template
object and it makes this function call
so I'm going to copy all of that to the
clipboard we execute that flex and we
have made an exquisite reference and so
that's a little belaboured but when i
try to answer our questions for people
and I try to run their code the two most
common ways that I fail are that they
haven't explicitly listed all the
packages they're using and I have to
either sleuth it out of them or figure
it out for myself and add those commands
or the objects that are referring to are
not available to me and so those are the
two reasons where I can't run their code
so on the rep Rex website I have a list
of do's and dont's that are distilled
from
of other really fantastic sources about
creating reproducible examples which are
referenced there but the three big big
high points are you need to write this
reproducible example using the smallest
the simplest and the most built-in data
set you can get away with and that is
very uncomfortable for people I'm going
to talk about that in a second
include commands on a ruthlessly strict
need to run basis so you really need to
strip your example down and then I say
pack it in pack it out and don't take
liberties with other people's computers
and this is referring to making sure
that if you create files you remove them
or if you change the working directory
you reset it if you change options you
reset them but basically leaving things
as you found them but um I want to talk
about so let's see here's here's what
that right page would look like if you
want to read it more but let me just
give a short example of something that a
lot of people struggle with which is
that they feel like they have some big
hairy data object and they can only show
their example using it so tricks to know
so the read CSV file you probably think
of as normally being a function that you
use to bring data sorry the read PSD
function is something you usually bring
delimited data in from a file but it
also has a text argument that allows you
to inline really tiny R objects and then
also just the data playing function
itself so I'm gonna rep record short cut
those two snippets of code and see
that's a very easy way to make a very
tiny data frame either inline using an
read CSV or sort of some first
principles using data frame and then if
you are a tiny verse adherent the Tibble
package is what takes care of the care
and feeding of Tibbals which are a
flavor of data frame
and the tribal function is extremely
useful for creating tiny little data
frames because it allows you to write it
in this really humane row-wise way like
the same way it would look in for
example in a CSV file so if I reference
this little snippet you'll see very very
similar output as what we just saw with
the base function but it allows you to
inline the creation in this case of a
two row two column data frame or you can
again use just the table function
directly and so if you make a lot of
references you get you get really good
at figuring out how to inline the
creation of very small objects of course
figuring out what's the smallest object
that still shows your problem is
difficult and we're going to talk about
that very end
okay another principle is that the
rhetoric should contain code I do not
have to run because a lot of your
readers have a great deal of our
experience and sometimes not always but
sometimes they can quickly see the point
without actually running the code but
that is greatly enhanced if they can see
the output instead of having to run it
in their head and in their imagination
and trying to figure out what's
happening it's just much easier if you
can actually see the output and so
that's why I think it's important that
your typical rec recs contains the code
and it also reveals the output being
produced by that code so here's an
example I took from the github
repository where the read our package is
developed because it's a perfect little
example and it probably was pretty used
with reference you can't tell and this
person is just reporting a bug but it's
like a great minimal example it says you
know if the header and your CSV contains
quoted new lines you get kind of a weird
column name and you get weird data and
the fact that this person provided a
small example and it completely shows
the problem I imagine is
the maintainer Jim Hester who's
listening to this fall to to quickly
label this as a bug and we've already
got at least one other user giving it a
thumbs up meaning they've experienced it
as well and so if you would only have
the code here I think you'd have a lot
less sort of quick engagement with this
issue okay so code that I can easily run
is very important we're going to keep
working with that issue so if that
person had instead copied and pasted the
output from their our console this is
what we would be faced with so if I were
Jim Hester and I needed to reproduce
this issue and make sure that it's still
a problem I have a lot of really
annoying editing to do so I have to get
rid of all the prompts at the beginning
of the lines I have to get rid of all
this output to isolate the three lines
of code that actually do anything
so copy paste from the our console hits
some of our checklist but it's not great
because it's very hard for the next
person to run this code worse than copy
paste is the screenshot so this of
course does again hit some of our
checklist it clearly shows the code and
the output but again if somebody else
wanted to check this and reproduce it
they actually have to retype everything
which frankly is never gonna happen
and so this is what I want to see in a
reference because it can be copy pasted
and run so I'm gonna prove that to you
right now so if I go to this issue on
github and I copy I could copy all of
this or I could as long as I get all the
commands I'm okay so I'm gonna put that
on my clipboard I'm gonna go back to our
maybe to make this really explicit I'll
show you what I copied all right that's
what I did so I can copy this again and
call Rex
and I get exactly what this person was
reporting on github so I've been able to
reproduce it very quickly from a copy
paste but as you saw rep Rex's like are
you sure you want to do this because I'm
I've got this output here and so if you
if you really want to get really clean
code from our rep Rex that someone else
has made you capture it and use one of
the undo functions and the reference
package I could use a reference clean
and I'll show you that right now
so here's what I copied from github so I
could copy that and call repres clean
and now if I paste you'll see all the
output has been eliminated and so that's
a slightly obscure thing you might want
to do but there are the full set of some
backwards functions and repre so it
helps you take code that people have
copied from the console or that they
have already made a reference from okay
so we've gotten to essentially the the
meet of the webinar now so if you were
really interested in basic usage you've
seen it now and now I'm going to go into
the shock-and-awe section where I run
through a lot of more interesting
features of the reference package that I
still think are pretty cool so the
slides show you what we're about to do
live so I'm going back to our studio and
I'm in a script called shock and awe I'm
gonna restart our just for good measure
so the first thing I want to show you is
how frictionless repres can make it to
talk to people about figures so I'm
gonna load the Gapminder data and
ggplot2 and I'm gonna make a plot with
ggplot2 so you see it down here in my
plots
pane so let's say that
there's something about this I don't
like or that I want to discuss with a
colleague I can use reference for this
so as usual I can select the snippet
copy to my clipboard and run Rex you're
gonna see all the same stuff so we've
got a nicely rendered rhetorics it
includes the figure watch this
I'm gonna go to a github repo that I
created just play around with I'm gonna
create a new issue I have a question
about this plot and I'm going to paste
let's look at what we've got we have the
usual sort of nicely formatted markdown
and look at this so when when reference
rendered this code it made your figure
and pushed it up to imager and dropped
this link into your markdown so if I
submit this issue people see my code and
they see the actual figure that you just
made so this is an example of one of the
cool things you can do that removes a
tremendous amount of friction if you're
trying to have a quick conversation with
somebody about code that produces
figures okay so we're gonna go back to
this shock-and-awe script and we're
gonna execute reference many times
showing some of the options and
different arguments you have so so far
I've only shown you referencing when the
source code is on the clipboard but
there are a lot of other ways to provide
the input so you can provide it directly
in the reference call as an expression
so here you see that the assignment of
X&Y gets done and we compute the
correlation between them there's also an
input argument that I'm actually not
going to demonstrate
you can provide the source as a file or
as a character vector reference by
default goes and does its work in the
session temp directory that's all part
of it
sandboxing all of your work but if your
repre for example file and put an output
it could be much easier to force
reference to work in your current
working directory so out file equals n/a
is shorthand for that so if I try to if
I ask are to write the first six letters
of the alphabet to a file without files
na all of a sudden these four files that
reference needs to create are being left
behind in my working directory instead
of in a temp directory and it's the r
script that reference makes it's the
HTML then it uses for the preview and
the markdown that it puts on the
clipboard for you so all those usual
files are left behind in a much more
accessible place but you'll notice it
has a god-awful file name because we
just created it out of thin air so if
you want to work somewhere specifically
and have nice filenames you could also
provide the base for that in out file
and now you see that it leaves the same
for files behind that they have a much
better file name okay so so far I've
been producing a reference output that's
optimized for github so it's producing
what's called github flavored markdown
but Stack Overflow is another common
target and that produces slightly
different looking markdown Stack
Overflow doesn't use fenced code blocks
that use an indented code box and let me
show you what this would look like I'm
gonna pretend like I'm gonna answer my
own question
on stackoverflow but I won't actually
submit this but now if you paste that
and to Stack Overflow it also has a
preview feature and it will be formatted
correctly for Stack Overflow you can
also make reference produce it creates
an R script which seems sort of weird
but an R script that includes the output
as comments and that is very handy for
pasting into an email or into slack so
I'm gonna show you the slack version of
that so this is me talking to myself on
slack I'm gonna create a code snippet
paste it
maybe I always have it set to R create a
snippet and that would create a little R
file in slack properly syntax
highlighted and again people could copy
paste it into R and run it or sometimes
you just want to inline it you don't get
the syntax highlighting but that also
looks quite nice
the final venue I'll talk about is RTF
the rich text format and this is a very
experimental venue it only works
probably on the Mac at this point
because I actually have to call an
external utility to do this but I'd like
to show you this and in fact it's how I
need the slides for this talk so you run
a little bit of code but now I can go
over to keynote or PowerPoint or
something and I could paste that in and
I'm getting rendered our code that is
properly syntax highlighted and that is
in fact how all the snippets in my
webinar was produced you can suppress
the inclusion of that little add at the
bottom or you can include it you can ask
for your reference to include session
info and for the github venue it can be
placed in this cute little collapsible
thing so
is a great thing to include if you think
for example that the bug you're
reporting
could possibly be related to the version
of software on your computer and I love
that it gets folded here so then
sometimes people include this one they
don't need to and it's kind of
overwhelming so the fact that we can put
it in this folding tag is really nice
Rep ryx can also use the styler package
to restyle your code so here's a really
I would say poorly formatted piece of
code so by default rep Rex trusts that
you know what you're doing and that you
like your formatting but if you don't
trust yourself
you can explicitly ask for reference to
restyle your code and give it a much
more conventional layout you can be
silly and change your comment string and
make it some sort of really fun if you
want rex is part of the tidy verse right
and so the tidy verse meta package can
be quite chatty at start up and tell you
all the packages that you just attached
and if there are conflicts between them
so we actually have a special argument
where you can control whether you want
that or not and usually you don't so we
default to silencing it and then the
last thing I'll show you is reference
can actually capture input that in an
interactive chef session shows up in
your console but it's actually being
sent to standard out further standard
error so I'm going to install a package
from github that requires compilation
this takes a moment so I'm gonna chat
over it but what you're gonna see when
this replica actually renders is that we
have captured everything that would
normally show up in the our console when
doing this so the stuff that is sort of
coming from our as well as the things
that are being sent standard output and
standard input
I was hoping that
you know that there we go okay and so
here's the output of installing the
bench package from github which does
require compilation and so this is the
part that's coming through sort of
normal our channels and this is
capturing what's being sent to standard
output and standard input so that was a
very quick live demo of some of the more
I don't know if they're really advanced
but features you don't need in every rep
racks but that you might need before
long a lot of the things that I showed
you toggling on and off you can actually
set up your own personal defaults for
these things by again putting some code
and your dart profile which we've
already talked about so this is just an
example of someone who hates the add
they always want to include session info
they always want to restyle their code
they have a whimsical sense of what the
comment string should be for output and
they they always want to see the tiny
first startup message so these are not
my defaults but it's an example of what
you can do and the last thing I'll show
you mechanically is most of the time I
do not do what I've shown you which is
copying code to the keyboard and then
going to the console and typing that
corrects there are two our studio
add-ins that really accelerate your rep
Rex life and one of them is called
render repres which launches a GUI I'll
show you that in a second
or repres selection literally references
the code that you have selected and it's
absolutely conceived for use for the
keyboard shortcut and our studio lets
you modify your keyboard shortcuts and
so i have bound that add-in to shift
command R this is how I usually use Rex
and for example hadley also it uses it a
lot he has bound it to something else
and let me go show you the add-in
so again I could select the snippet of
code that made that figure and launch
the add-in and so this allows you to
specify a lot of the things that you can
specify on the call by clicking so I am
going to take the source from the
current selection let's target
stackoverflow and yes let's append
session info click render and the usual
things happen and the usual output
appears down here and stackoverflow
doesn't have the capability to support
this little folding toggle so the
session then but actually gets dumped in
there and it's full glory so that is
these are two other ways to get your
input into the reference function that
actually are probably more humane than
typing it all the time all right the
last thing I'll say we have I'll try to
go quite quickly he's already at 25
minutes
is talking a little bit about the human
side of making reproducible examples and
now this has nothing to do with the
reference package it's just about asking
questions so that they actually get
answered and I like this image because
it conveys somehow the you know we're
talking about programming maybe we're
all supposed to be acting like robots
and people often seem to assume that
they're talking to robots but that
there's a lot of humans involved in this
process and I want to warn you I'm
getting a little bit of tough love here
there's there's been a lot of all
they're probably still not enough talk
of experts being empathetic to newcomers
and question askers but since this is a
talk targeted at people asking questions
and preparing examples I also want to
say it has to go the other direction as
well so bear with me for a moment here
but I need to say
you know with all the love in the world
sometimes people come with a question
and they have like a very rigid theory
about what's wrong or how they should be
solving a problem but if your theory
about what was going wrong was so great
like you you wouldn't be here asking
this question right now and this is the
origin of why people really want to see
code instead of having sort of a prose
discussion because it's very hard
sometimes to tell what people are really
talking about the other like phenomenon
I want to link this to is I don't know
if you've had this experience but if
you've ever tried to help for example
one of your relatives sort out a
computer problem over the phone it can
be extremely difficult a lot of what
they're saying doesn't really make sense
they don't use the words you're used to
to refer to things you just feel like
you can't really get a grip on things
and and this is basically what it feels
like when you're trying to answer
someone's programming question just
based on English prose and again like
this is why people constantly push you
to actually just show a small piece of
code removes all sorts of ambiguity so
let's assume that everybody the question
asker and the question answerer is
acting in good faith and if they're not
then they're irrelevant to me okay so
everyone's in good faith it turns out
that experts posting on public sites I
actually are afraid to post code that
doesn't work and so another reason why
these people want to see your code is
you know they're not just reading it and
guessing most of these people are
actually running your code proving that
their proposed solution works and then
they post it when they know that it's
safe to do so
and this was a big like revelation to me
I really used to think that the people I
looked up to as experts just knew all
this stuff by heart and they were
answering all these questions just off
the cuff and then it gradually dawned on
me that part of why they're experts or X
behavior is that they are constantly
running lots of small examples and
experiments so sharing your problem in
code is extremely fruitful making a good
reference is a lot of work like
sometimes you think I can only show my
problem in my art session and I haven't
restarted R for seven months and it
requires the full data set from my
thesis and that isn't fact true it is a
lot of work but you're asking other
people to solve a problem and so this is
part of meeting them halfway but it
turns out you get a lot out of this as
well so let's be very selfish if you
make a good rep Recor hairy messy
problem and if you reproduce other
people's problems
even reproducing other people's problems
is a real service and then sometimes
you're going to be able to solve them it
turns out this discipline it's like
playing scales or you know serving over
and over again like you actually get
better at programming by doing this and
the last selfish point that I'll make is
it turns out when you sit down to make a
good reference out of your problem and
you keep it self-contained you strip
down your giant hairy data set to the
smallest data set that reproduces the
problem it is amazing how often you end
up answering your own question in the
privacy of your own home and you didn't
have to make yourself vulnerable to
other people so this is a great
revelation and I think the reason this
works is that when you have a problem
it's very easy to just keep going in
circles and banging your head against
the desk but there's something about
preparing it for other people and the
rhetorics package is also being a real
hard-ass about making sure that you're a
problem is self-contained it kind of
knocks you out of that very unproductive
place and gets you back on the path of
actually working the problem so most
people report this when they first start
making reproducible examples is that
it's kind of amazing how often this
exercise means you actually answer your
own question
I will skip over this section since
we're out of time and I didn't think
people wanted to know it but it's here a
little bit about what's happening behind
the scenes and I will conclude I want to
give a huge thank you to you age' and
all the people who have brought us the
our markdown package and pan doc the
rhetorics package is just a wrapper
around those things and I mean that in
both senses like that is literally all
that it is
so in some sense there's not much there
there but on the other hand when I first
made it and then especially now that
I've worked on it more there's actually
a lot more going on like the friction
that it removes this isn't is friction
that is really important to remove I
think so in any case it could not be
possible without our Mac done and pan
dock and in fact I should thank all the
co-authors of repres and there's a lot
of people who have contributed to it and
a lot of users who've been extremely
generous with their bug reports and
feature requests and reporting how
things work on different platforms so to
conclude go forth and engage in very
precise code heavy conversations about
our I'm going to take a look at the
questions now okay okay so I can see
these you cannot what did I leave
PowerPoint on that's a decent slide okay
can reference be able to also capture
variables in the environment and include
in the reproducible example currently it
cannot and that is very intentional
because we we really prioritize this
sandboxing I am actually contemplating
basically creating a back door for this
mostly because of creating RTS snippets
but at the moment it cannot and that is
intentional but you know I'm open to
people sharing their use case about why
that should be but basically if you do
this
yeah there are ways you could do it that
actually make those objects available to
other people as well but it becomes a
much heavier weight package so so far we
have not done that often times this is a
continuation of that question the issue
is buried in some part of larger code
and rather than going back to the places
where that data is gathered or
calculated wouldn't it be nice to grab
the variable name current state again
like yes and no I would say extracting
that out is perhaps part of your job oh
I'm not realizing that some of these
questions have been answered
does repres the function actually check
that the code is self-contained or does
it just generate a template it just
generates a template so the way you
would find out that your code is not
self-contained is that you get an error
but it's explicitly allows errors
because sometimes you're using rep X to
show errors so no it is just it's on you
the human to decide if you're getting
the result you expect does read are read
CSV support the text argument as an
alternative to file or is that only in
rideau c sv ried are also does this it
also supports the inline creation of a
data frame it does it through its
primary argument so you would want to
read the help for me underscore CSV but
in fact it's actually sort of even a
smaller departure from your usual use I
think I have another instance of the
same question which is could reference
help you package up an existing data set
and stick it into your data that
reference Deusen don't document outlines
various ways of doing this for
sample D put is a great function if you
have a slightly awkward object and you
simply cannot make your point without
using it D put at least creates a
representation of that that you can put
into our reference but so far you're
right I have not made this terribly easy
and at least the story I tell myself is
that finding a really simple object and
making it but is intrinsically part of
the reference task but this does come up
over and over again can you do a
reference for a shiny it's not easy I
think the shiny team is or has developed
their own webpage talking about how you
create shiny rep Rex's like and they
don't use this package so now I'm
talking about rep Rex's as a concept 10
rep Rex produce interactive plots all I
will say is I have not done so so I'll
end on this question I don't know it
would have to be tried but what I will
say the side that I skipped over what
actually happens so currently reference
works by dumping your our code into a
templated our script and I have
contemplated revisiting this and dumping
it into a into an armed markdown file
and then it would be much more capable
in terms of what you can do like in some
ways there's a lot of equivalence
between rendering our scripts and our
markdown files but there are some key
differences and so I could imagine that
the ability to include interactivity is
probably present if you're using our
markdown and could easily be absent if
you're using our alright I think I will
leave it
here and clue the webinar
you
[Music]